a lot of you have been asking me what
I've been up to lately so here's a quick
update as well as some behind the scenes
of my latest la trip boom we have a very
special guest a very good-looking and
very smart guys dr. Mike you might know
him from Instagram he has 2.5 million
followers thank you guide his hot water
better and why is a cold shower but warm
water is better because cold water
shunts blood away from your stomach so
you don't absorb it as readily you're
very knowledgeable very visually
appealing and we really appreciate you
being here while I was in LA I was able
to catch up with some of my old friends
in fact my buddy Marco he was there at
the same time on a business venture were
able to catch up he introduced me to his
adorable dog Titan in 2015 during my
little viral moment of Fame the first
nationally syndicated TV show that
invited me on was the dr. show and they
invited me on obviously as Instagram
sexiest doctor as a guest and it was a
really great experience I was able to
talk about how I'm passionate about
medicine talk a little bit about my past
and my future and now to be invited to
the same program as a host as a co-host
with these doctors that have been doing
this for 10 years is such an amazing
opportunity it really makes me feel like
the whole situation has come full circle
originally I came on as a guest now I'm
coming out as a co-host it shows that I
wasn't just popular 15 minutes of fame
because of my looks I have a medical
message that I want to get out there to
you I want to have fun with medicine and
I think because you've been so receptive
and showed me so much support it's
because of that I'm able to get an
opportunity like co-hosting a doctor's
show
I was also invited to the premiere of a
movie Flatliners and it's a movie based
on medical students who were trying to
kill themselves and bring them back in
order to experience the afterlife I
would like you to stop my heart you give
it one minute and then you bring me back
the one thing I'll say about the movie
is that it totally surprised me because
I thought it was gonna be maybe a little
science fiction about medical students
and how medicine can give you a peek
into the afterlife when in reality it
turned out to be a scary movie I'm a
baby when it comes to that so half of
the movie I was watching like this so if
you saw me in the theater don't judge me
already so where he headed - Ricky
Dillon's house right now we're gonna
surprise you with a collab next week or
maybe the week after so stay tuned the
most unique part of my trip was I was
able to do something I've never done
before and that's meet this adorable pig
named Luna Ricky was able to show me how
smart this pig is how if you call the
pig the pig actually comes over I'm
totally jealous because I can't have a
pet pig New York City has an explicit
ban on pet pigs
there are new media outlets out there
like cheddar Mashable instant and I do
visit some of those outlets because I
believe that they're doing a great job
for society they're taking the concepts
and the format of a traditional news
network but making it a little bit more
millennial friendly and I could totally
get behind that because if I can have my
message reach anybody its Millennials
the younger generation the biggest
impact you can make on your health is in
your group so take listen the reason you
see me meeting all these television
executives is because I see a fantastic
opportunity right ahead of them I'm able
to reach and help millions of people
right in their homes by being on
television and giving my medical advice
my goal is not necessarily to make it
big on TV my goal is to reach the most
amount of people possible with my
medical advice as you can tell I love
traveling and if you travel also click
this link to see my travel tips video
which give you all the insider tips on
how I fight jet lag how I stay healthy
and how I pack effectively when I go on
my trips it should go without saying but
all of these amazing opportunities that
I've been getting recently really have
come because of your support your
support for this YouTube channel your
support for my Instagram so I have to
give you a huge thing it really means a
great deal to come here give me a hug
[Music]